your fans are so in love with you when
that when people heard you're coming on
the show finally because your fans have
been since episode 1 talking about you
being on the show and we're five years
later finally you're on the show which
is great but they can't shut up about
you so why do people get so obsessive
with you do you think oh well I should
in fairness point out that I'd like a
concept I think I have a very polarizing
effect on people so I either have fans
who like my stuff or I have people who
think I have the most punchable face in
the universe and I remind them of like
the frat boy jock who like slap their
girlfriend's ass in college or I don't
know what it is even though that I was
neither of those but for whatever reason
I get these sort of very positive or
very negative effect from people which
I'm fine with because I don't want to
end up in the middle but I think that I
really try to be what you see is what
you get and I don't think that you I
mean you've spent time with me socially
I think how I am now is how I am when
we're hanging out it's very own person
and I am also I try to be very open
about my mistakes and my disasters and
it's like oh yeah it's coming to the
experiments like that idea to fly in
stem cell growth factor from Israel to
inject up and down my spine with like a
black market chemist maybe not the best
idea whoa whoa whoa did you actually
attempt that I don't yeah I did and I
guess attempt is probably a good word
for it because I had in that same
session I broke the record for clinic in
injections and this is with a very
questionable guy who will remain unnamed
but who works with a lot of athletes who
are taking will call them extra
supplementation for their performances
and I had a number of injuries I wanted
his help fixing and so I did have stem
saw a growth factor igf-1 growth hormone
a bunch of things turned into a cocktail
and injected in different sites in my
body I had some tennis elbow and at that
point we did something called PRP which
is very interesting
it's a platelet-rich plasma so you take
out a whole blood sample in effect when
was this by the way this was probably
2008-2009 I
done some stuff since then but that was
then because this is something that Kobe
Bryant is since done the plate lid thing
oh yeah absolutely knighted PRP even
prior to that so the good news about
being an early adopter with these weird
edge cases and professional sports is
you get to see things before other
people the bad news is that sometimes
that means you're you're taking the
arrows on the front lines right and
being the human guinea pig who creates
the list of known side-effects include
you know you're the guy who's like let's
do that so wait the guy comes and he's
got this cocktail of your platelet rich
blood right and they they put that
exactly so they spin it out and then
they reject those growth factors into
the site of injury to among other things
sort of mimic a an acute injury so to
marshal the body's resources and this
injection to repair the site the problem
is they botched that injection and they
did it through a thicker area of skin on
the elbow than they should have
why is that important well the reason
that's important is that if you use
alcohol or betadine or whatever to
disinfect the surface of the skin great
but if you push the needle through five
layers of skin or very thick skin then
you can push bacteria from those
internal layers into the joint capsule
which is exactly what happened so I got
a staph bacterial infection of my elbow
which it's became about as large as a
football I had to go to the emergency
room the guy who the guy who took fluid
out of my elbow I mean doc view people
in the ER supposed to be very clinical
and and literal and Spock life and and
he goes holy [ __ ] like they taught us in
medical school that 30 CC's was the
limit we're taking 50 plus cc's out here
what did you do to your elbow and he
just totally lost his composure which I
thought was hilarious and when a tennis
elbow the tennis elbow turned into a
bigger problem real and it was because I
had this massive I had that surgery and
get it cleaned out and blah blah blah
and we died from septic shock I mean if
you can you hear it got your blood if I
had what if I had if I had waited a week
I could have had systemics
infection or an unusable elbow right
yeah so the point is let me do these
experiments for you and then report back
and tell you how to dial it down maybe
40% and what works and what doesn't and
that is super compelling making you have
a PRP is something that's become much
more mainstream and I mean there's
things that I wrote about legal now it's
it's came out of Germany yeah every NBA
player is doing in every yeah there's
some pretty there's some pretty amazing
effects that can be gotten from it and a
lot of the things that were written
about in the 4-hour body you know in
that was published in 2010 but written
in 2008-2009 are now becoming mainstream
so you know Gretchen Reynolds in The New
York Times is talking about cold
exposure and fat loss and adiponectin
and all these things or the microbiome
and how things like Splenda can
completely screw up your intestinal gut
flora so are you talking about these
things and it turns out also you were
right that these artificial sweeteners
make you fat because they spike your
insulin etc etc yeah just because it's
non-caloric doesn't mean that it won't
have an effect on your pancreas or on
your microbiome and what's amazing is
you can take whether it's you know fecal
transplants or otherwise you can take
these sort of destroyed intestinal
microbiome transplant them to someone
else and they'll develop glucose
intolerance it's it's amazing so I'm
actually thinking about well well I'm
thinking about doing a receiving a fecal
transplant like trying to identify like
the the Michael Jordan of microbiomes
this might be the first time somebody
said they were gonna receive a fecal
transplant on the show I'm quite sure
that's very likely